[Music]
the search is on for two killers who
broke out of a maximum-security prison
in upstate New York more than a thousand
searchers are starting day 21 of the
manhunt both convicted murderers are
considered to be very dangerous
breaking news manhunts over the
remaining fugitive David sweat shot and
captured in northern New York after more
than three weeks on the run do you
remember that story I do that 2015
manhunt for escaped inmates Richard Matt
and David sweat made headlines all
across the country and after weeks on
the run Matt was killed by a Border
Patrol tactical team sweat was caught
two days later the search cost New York
State more than 23 million dollars and
now the story is being told in a seven
part series on Showtime
the division of CBS it is called escape
at Dannemora Emmy Award winner Ben
Stiller executive produces and directs
the series oscar-winning actress
Patricia Arquette plays former prison
employee Joyce Mitchell who helped the
inmates escape in this clip from the
premiere Mitchell is questioned by
investigators no one came to asked me
that's all I'm into what it's trying to
help when you spoke to the State Police
you asked the detectives six times
whether the inmates have been captured
no of course I did yeah he wanted to be
caught right that's Hannie but he wants
well not everybody I mean some people
like to see him killed
they gotta hurt anybody they should be
killed
yeah better for you if they die but is
it what does that mean
wouldn't it be convenient to be the only
person who lives to tell the story sure
sure ben stiller her join us now that
was raised that was a good tease Claire
and Patricia let's start with you
because everybody is watch this it's
like wait a minute how did she become
that person you look a lot different
yeah well we had these gigantic contact
lenses these teeth so you had an
underbite and these wigs and and you put
on 40 pounds right yeah and gain some
weight a little thing yeah yeah yeah
yeah Patricia totally you know just went
for it and and I think as an actress she
just she doesn't worry about anything
other than trying to be the character
and not worrying about being likable or
in any way having to draw the audience
in she trusts this is my feeling about
you as an actress they just trust that
if you're a human being and you're
finding you know who that person is
inside that people will then you know
see that and she was such a fascinating
figure right Tilly because here she was
on the inside and not only having a
relationship a sexual relationship but
was helping them right yeah yes yeah she
was the civilian supervisor in the
tailor shop and she was overseeing 40
inmates who were making uniforms for for
a company it's a real company called
core craft and so yes she was the
dynamic there is you know is pretty
obvious and she was being inappropriate
with at least a couple of inmates are
you suggesting it was pretty
inappropriate sometimes especially when
I sixteen-year-old stepson but when you
watch a character like yours you'd go
back to I know that actress that's
Patricia Arquette I never once thought
that you became Tilly well he had a
couple weird experiences on the set I I
knew David Morris we'd done a movie
together I said hi to him early when I
first got to work for the makeup test
and then later and when I had all my
makeup on I was outside and he was
talking to somebody and I started
chiming in and he just was looking at me
like
he just thought I was some crazy lady
who was talking to him and it happened
to Benny with Benicio - mm-hmm they were
like David didn't know that was you Wow
and I sat down next to Benicio during
the the makeup test he took oh my god
you became telly yeah was it important
for you to find anything sympathetic
about her character you know what I feel
like especially with actresses we're
always expecting people to be empathetic
mmm you know oftentimes our parts are
like how do you make this empathetic and
I just don't care about that yeah it's
like I think like Ben said if you just
ground it in what this person really
feels there's human components I think
we can all understand man what did you
learn from visiting David sweat in
prison a lot about the details of the
escape we spent about we had two
separate visits you met him also but you
know a lot about the details of the
escape his relationship with Richard
Matt who he escaped with which was kind
of you know it's an interesting
relationship because they weren't
necessarily friends but they he helped
Matt Todd sweat how to paint in in in
prison and and then they you know how to
both want to have this mutual goal of
wanting to get out and then when they
got out together their personalities
were pretty different and and so I
learned a little bit about the dynamic
between the two of them I think there
was a friendship of some type between
them that developed though as I
understand it you passed on at first but
then went back to it after the Inspector
General report yeah at first there just
wasn't enough information about what
really happened and that was what was
interesting to me is what has something
like this happen in 2015 in this day and
age these two guys are able to saw their
way out of their cells and when the
Inspector General report came out it had
all these great details it was like a
hundred and sixty page novel almost so
that became our source material for
watching the series you really learn
about the intricacies inside of a prison
right and the sort of level of
hierarchies not just among the prisoners
but among the guards in the relationship
it's place I mean we shot in several
different prisons and it's such a
pressure cooker I mean it's dangerous
for the for the inmates it's dangerous
for the guards there's a
different whole survival mechanism at
Waco system and this also takes place in
a community which we were all the name
of which everybody was repeating for
several days but you went and you were
there what was it what was the
community's relationship with this story
and the prison and the prisoners I think
it's complicated because Dannemora the
town it's a very small town the prison
is almost bigger than the town and yeah
the media descended when the escape
happened for about a month and then left
and then we came back a couple years
later and we're there and I think you
know the people there were concerned
about being portrayed just as you know
this place where these you know the
people this prison screwed up when the
reality is that you know there are a lot
of things that contributed to what
happened in terms of just like just that
the dynamic that's there from this
prison being there for over a hundred
years and you know the complacency that
that happened was it was based in just
you know the fact that this place has
been there that long and generations of
people have done things the same way for
years and years and that's a bigger
question about the prison system in the
u.s. so I think they wanted us to make
sure that we told a story that showed
the whole right you know the whole
spectrum the church can I ask you about
the Oscar when you want in 2014 and you
gave that passionate speech about
women's equality and equal pay have you
seen things change I'm excited the last
couple years like on our our show to
have a female boom operator to have a
female DP I'm seeing on sets a lot more
females in the crew and throughout and a
lot more women writing and and also I
mean when I gave that speech it wasn't
necessarily about Hollywood per se yeah
so California we've passed Fair Pay laws
women have come up to me and say I got a
ten thousand dollar check because my
boss told me they were not paying me
equally and then I got so excited and
then I got so sad because I realized
this been happening for years
and that impacts my Social Security and
it's estimated that if we paid women
equally half the child poverty in
America would be eradicated overnight
well it was true as is clear was an
important issue for you it came from the
heart and it resonated with everyone and
something we're still talking about
today well unfortunately the states that
most have the largest pay gap for women
have no legislation pending
whatsoever to change it well we'd love
to have you back to talk about that
issue thank you
yeah and congratulations on this serious
nice to meet ya good to see you escape
from Dannemora premieres Sunday night on
Showtime and today on CBS this morning's
podcast we talked to journalists Chelsea
Rose Marcia's who covered the Dannemora
prison break and manhunt for the New
York Daily News now she has a new book
about what happened while a state wild
escape features information she learned
from interviews with David sweat and
Joyce Mitchell dad you look too on your
way out
you can hear the podcast on Apple's
podcast app and all major audio
platforms